Christmas came early for me.
Thanks to Lowe's, I finally got a new sweeper.
So I got this one off of their website.
I got a 10 Co I floor three complete,
which sweeps and mops your floor at the same time,
which is a game changer to me.
It moves so nice, and it picks up everything.
As you can see. As you go forward,
it sweeps, and when you pull back,
it mops. I put it to the test behind my couch,
the dog hair accumulates.
It did a great job picking up all the dog hair
and mopping the floor clean.
There was literally nothing left on the ground after I was done.
If you're looking for a new sweeper that is quick and easy to use,
I definitely recommend this one.
Look at all the nasty stuff it picked up.
Even the kids played in the Lowe's box hours after we got it.
Thanks, lows.